people of color are magical and mystical
and powerful and beautiful and spiritual
and strong and excellent at what they do
there's just so much power and talent I
can see where if people were insecure I
guess you'd be scared by it but it's so
much easier to just write and bring it
and just thank the universe for giving
us people of color because it's a gift
Ellen Pompeo getting candid about race
on Jada Pinkett Smith's Facebook watch
it series red tabletop if we don't talk
about it we're not gonna get to the
other side we're just gonna you know
things are just gonna stay in the cracks
and fester so the more that we can bring
these difficult subjects to light and
talk about it the more we can purify
these subjects and bring them into
something new and so that's why it's
important for me don't feel like you
have to tiptoe I'm not afraid to talk
about race a lot of people get very
nervous when you bring it up yeah and I
understand why they do but I am Not
Afraid and if you're afraid to talk
about it then that's a problem right
there to talk about it more right if
you're afraid
Helen is married to a black man musician
Chris Ivory and together they have three
biracial children son Eli and daughter
Sienna and Stella that's the perfect
number three is the perfect number yes
it's a lot and it's great and love them
all so my son looks completely white you
couldn't even tell he has any brown in
the middle yeah there is no escaping
when your skin is dark and me sticking
up or celebrating brown people does not
mean you're anti white I celebrate
anything black I inevitably get a
million comments one comments or can you
tell whether the comments are coming
from white people or are they coming
from
of course they are they are threatened
by my love of people of color or black
culture yeah Ellen says she does all she
can to help change the way people think
and it goes always she shared a story
about a little girl who came over for a
playdate and I introduced myself and I
said I'm
tell us mom's a little black girl and
she looked at me and she was like almost
scared you know this white lady but
again non trusting yes possibly that's
why that experience of being in my house
and meeting me was good for her right
see that all white people aren't what
you think and Ellen's working to make
change in the industry - she was fired
up with et at a red carpet that featured
few diverse faces behind the cameras
back in October I want to see behind the
scenes and below the line crew look
different everybody realizes that the
talent that people have to have more
opportunities with respect to the talent
we see on screen I want to see press
lines I want to see press junkets I want
to see film critics I want to see the
people that we don't see I want to see
that change I want to see more inclusion
there and I'm not seeing it I'm not
seeing it tonight there's a couple of
women on the carpet the photographers
and there's always a few women but when
I look down I see the majority of
photographers are white men and that's a
problem
[Music]